no you're so weird
Wow she's a BTS penikett yeah so is the
star mm-hmm
what's up everybody we are back with
another video a very special video our
secret wedding video secret wedding yeah
we told him went to Vegas on like a
drunken night and we had a GoPro rolling
the whole time he blacked out but we
have it all recorded for you guys no it
wasn't me it was here in LA and we
didn't black out and it was all planned
alright so are you guys are probably
wondering what do you mean secret
wedding exactly one year ago from today
the day that we're uploading this video
which is May 19th we got legally married
in Los Angeles
happy Anniversary honey mmm which is
this is the day that we're gonna be
celebrating anyway he's a France wedding
that was just the first one party we're
not really focusing so much on that date
but today is very special because it is
our anniversary and we really wanted to
share with you guys
our secret wedding and the reason why
the secret wedding is because we didn't
want to remove the specialness or like
the the what specialness yeah from the
France wedding so we didn't publicly
announce that we were legally married by
the time we had the France wedding
because we didn't want you guys to be
like oh why are you getting married
twice we did have to get married twice
if we were trying to do our wedding in
France because in order to get legally
married in France you have to be a
resident of friend and yet to speak
French for like five years and you need
to know how to like do no you just have
to live there for at least two months or
something like that it was too long for
us yeah it was way too long it was to
take a two-month vacation just to go
live over there just to get legally
married there so we didn't want to do
all that but it all worked out because
we ended up having an LA wedding and
people that weren't able to go to France
were able to make it through this way so
we wanted to share with you guys footage
from that date
what were you about to do we okay so
it's like midnight the night before
we're getting married in the courthouse
in the courthouse I didn't at the
paracin but the the LA one for the
government
all right stuff and we are gonna do a
little bit of a cultural thing right now
we're supposed to tomorrow on the actual
wedding day but we're wearing all red
tea ceremony super Chinese you know I'm
really looking forward is because I want
to really embrace both of our culture's
especially since we're getting married
it's such a life-changing event and
we're merging our lives together you
together forever so the fact that we're
doing this right now it means it means
nothing to me like it means a lot to me
the fact that we're doing something
that's supported yogurt culture I don't
know how you feel about it but I'm
really looking forward to this moment
if we're doing the Chinese stuff I
rather do this stuff we're like the
attests the couple's strength together
there's like wedding games are supposed
to do and like one of the games is to
put a raw egg up the pant sleeve
team work it up all the way through the
arm sleeve and if you can get it all the
way through without breaking the egg
then your marriage is gonna survive do
you want to do that right now no I think
we're too tired to do it right now
yeah midnight and then I don't know if
we could do them prays to kids that
we're gonna mess up our stuff yeah it
only works though if you're worrying the
Chinese pajamas - oh well thanks for
doing this the tea ceremony so we got
the tea Oh actually there's no team
can't wait well the one with the tea is
over there I'll go over there just
pretend so we got the D we have a tea
mama and Baba are here
so my parents flew in and it was late
they decided that they wanted us to do
the tea ceremony improve our last minute
the entire day I was filming JK Nia's I
didn't get home until super Spain but
finally when I got home that's what your
mom was like come on it's tradition and
we got to do it it's not a wedding
unless you do the tea ceremony and like
bootlegged it up yeah well yeah it was
super bootleg yeah I mean if y'all seen
the actual Paris wedding video that's
the tea ceremony uh how it should have
been done yeah but we did our way at
home and lucky we had to read pillows
from you on look at those red pillows so
the place is kind of a mess because Keri
and Diana are staying right here in the
living room so we don't have an extra
bedroom I think okay we gotta get this
done so you can go to sleep like six
o'clock tomorrow no I have to leave the
house by 7:30 get my hair and makeup
done yeah I get your beauty sleep in
mm-hmm you need anything
[Music]
tiny we're doing this no no it's not
about you guys I don't care about the
tradition is a tradition that come here
about procedures I care about you guys
oh you're sick again eyes again
I'm just gonna take pictures okay honey
honesty how do you feel about everything
what's going on in your life right now
how you feel about that
oh yeah yes there's anything to change
do you think yeah it's gonna be the same
huh house am I so special you think why
is this so spendings changing what's so
special then hated about wearing his
suit tomorrow
can't we just need it okay thank you and
I wish both of you grow old together
love each other forever and grow a
beautiful family with beautiful kids and
grandchildren
and here's a little thank-you as we were
doing the tea ceremony
my parents sprung a surprise on us and
they had a reason why they really wanted
to do the tea ceremony and it shot yeah
oh yeah this is a tradition thing what
does it call the Lacey Lacey yeah it's
gave us like see opening this what what
no thank you thank you thank you Oh
[Laughter]
additionally I should give you some
jewelry
thank you I mean there's another one of
these companies no I think what's going
on today is wedding day thank you
I like your suit thank you nice choice
Emma Marcus it was a goon hey
congratulations thank you love you baby
29 years ago May 6 1 now 29 years after
you're getting married
building up family I'm really proud of
you love you forever baby what what's
going on today you're getting married
uh-huh you are going to sign a long-life
contract and it's gonna be good
any advice for me no I think it's about
time in fact it's about time
so yeah advices that stay cool whole
your temperament and everything can be
talked about me and Papa everything so I
don't get not argument or anything so I
know your mom's 45 years ago maybe 45
years oh yeah really I was 11
yeah go into 12 13 14 so we know each
other for a long time too long so there
for you today is my one and only
brother's wedding I've never been to a
wedding that was so close to me before
every other wedding I've been to with
some random relative that I hardly ever
speak to so I'm excited I'm happy for
you and next time hopefully will be me
yeah
it's our fifth year anniversary too by
the way so this marks the five-year
anniversary of when TIFF and I started
dating and this is the one year
anniversary of the proposal which is why
we're getting married today
it was so funny so we had planned it out
for us to film well that's right and so
I was supposed to take a camera with me
while I went to go get ready and I
totally forgot about it because I was so
nervous I'm like oh my gosh I'm gonna
get married today this is so exciting
and so nerve-wracking and so Diana
accompanied me to go get my hair and
makeup done with URI so we went over to
her salon super early in the morning and
I was so nervous like after we finished
getting ready
I couldn't even Drive I was like shaking
I like all my really to the Cortney and
I was just like Diana I'm so sorry can
you drive my car like please like I just
I can't focus right now my nerves are
going crazy I was so nervous we end up
getting to the courthouse and then we
did the whole like first look things
super dinky outside of my car that was
my love hug thank you that's when it hit
me closing my eyes okay
I'm gonna see my bride for the first
time how she lick
I like it
oh man alright only we're not allowed to
kiss each other as Mansur so sweaty
hey you're so bad when I finally saw you
that's when it kind of hit me like woah
this is my way Dave this is like the big
day this is like the day that every kid
like guy or girl you know thinks about
when they're a little kid and you're
like no you know it's like today's the
day and she's here and this is that's
what she looks like today and this is
like cemented in our memories forever so
yeah it was huge
I remember when like right before I
opened the doors just like that's
happening we're doing it you nervous I'm
so you're really nervous I know you're
nervous
our kids are so sweaty right now it's
not too late you can walk away right now
just run away right now I'm just nervous
where everything that just happened
smoothly it's a big moment it's a big
event I'm just really nervous because of
how big and important
[Music]
you know this morning I made the most
stereotypical groom mistake ever breath
the ring I forgot the Rings I only got
only got like two minutes away from the
house if I realized it wasn't because I
that's the only thing I kept saying I'm
like I don't have the Rings I have the
papers that don't have the Rings make
sure you get the ring I knew you're
gonna forget this I'm glad you look good
[Music]
let me see your outfit I did go look
slick real quick model I think what made
it even more nerve-wracking one it's us
going through it together but then when
you have family friends and like it just
gets kind of overwhelming because
everyone was on you
everyone's like showing us the love and
I was so happy that part in jewelry
wouldn't be there for at least the Bears
are here yeah well you guys are still
asking like I see random comments like
walking for new didn't make it to the
Paris wedding because she was heavily
pregnant yeah the doctor said not to
travel
we are gathered here in the presence of
these witnesses for the purpose of
uniting in matrimony
Kacey Chan and Tiffany Del Rio the
contract of marriage is most solemn and
it is not to be entered into lightly but
thoughtfully and seriously and with the
deep realization of its obligations and
responsibilities Casey do you take
Tiffany to be your lawfully wedded wife
yes I do yes I thought it was really
charming how you messed up it was cute
and just added more personality to the
whole experience just and Tiffany do you
take Casey to be your lawfully wedded
husband do you both promise to love and
comfort one another to honor and keep on
another in sickness and in health and
prosperity and adversity to forsake all
others
faithful to each other
seongjo Sheldon
so by virtue of the authority vested
[Applause]
and I was just so happy on my brothers
where he wouldn't be there as well
because they couldn't make it to France
and so they were at least there for the
LA wedding and my brother Christian I
remember him posted on snapchat he's
like a little congratulations my sister
and I was like Christian can you please
delete it because we're not trying to
announce I'm Adam Zelena snap so bad for
that are you dude you could save it in
your temporal Christian you could post
now that same phone anymore yeah and it
was so cool cuz LAX's they wouldn't see
they - I know yeah like he's the reason
why we've been if you couldn't go to the
France one because it's parents
anniversary something yeah yeah
something else on the same exact day we
were only allowed to invite I think it
was a 15 15 p.m. or 10 or 15 so there
was the rouse ruff yeah there was more
people we wish we could have had there
there's two rings now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
therefore now you do I have two dads
[Music]
your son's a married man
yes how's it feel good very good
I like one tip Joe close now open
another child to know about you I feel
great you're married now I know did you
feel like 2-butene beasts like magic
does rolling around us as my husband
I know another name changes petal change
you know you went from boyfriend
girlfriend fiance now husband and wife
husband and wife husband away so crazy
I'm on a cloud baby yes when after the
courthouse wedding
we started vlogging in the car but we
completely forgot to check that the mic
was on so we have like this whole
interview like post wedding they're
talking about our feelings
yeah like so so like do you feel like we
need to learn how to lip read what did
we sing them and out of everything that
was said the only thing I could figure
out was you're talking about creamer to
be cute it's a very specific lip but we
got facial reactions and we looked happy
yeah definitely we were very happy very
so then afterward we've decided to have
Korean barbeque and if you know us
Korean barbeque it has a very special
place in our hearts
a long long taco at a rooftop party at
if they don't know what Korean barbeque
was and so for six months we planned a
Korean barbecue thing never happened one
fateful night on May 19th
we had a Korean barbecue and became
official that night and May 19th is the
Korean barbecue night which we celebrate
every single year till this day so
that's the reason why we decided on
Korean barbecue and so it was really
special to us to have everyone there
just everyone enjoying a good time
together and just cooking in the grill
and getting everyone's clothes dirty
kimchi juices on everyone's suits and
dresses yeah no one eats like a savage
where you talk to that I do and I get it
comes back honestly you're right though
because I think I did stay my white
dress we got some kimchi on it's almost
as if at Korean barbecue places the more
you try not to get dirty is when you do
get dirty it's one thing the grills no
sizzle glasses every time I would wear
glasses or Korean barbecue my glasses be
okay five years ago we were doing this
relations
thank you
coming here waking me awakened me way
it was memorable very much I like that
way it was very very intimate and then I
remember we came home we spent some time
to sitting on our balcony yeah we were
taking photos of like that was the first
time we saw like our rings on her hands
especially in yours today
I already got used to the engagement
ring on my finger yeah but then she it
was like the first time he had a ring on
his finger and not where save photos are
like oh my gosh we're married we're
married but we can't see anything until
after July oh my I remembered if you
come like yeah I'm in it by the end of
the night beginning of the next day I
was like all right till we meet the
pair's no it's all forever forever
but anyway thank you guys so much for
watching our secret wedding video hope
you enjoyed it make sure you give this
video a big thumbs up and if you're new
make sure to subscribe
what's the and signal for subscribe
thumbs up subscribe it's great you
should make one what is it that's great
it's a bell there we go
anyway bye
[Music]
are we good yo
[Music]